on va parler maintenant d'un de laurence
boccolini qui a poussé un coup de gueule
cette semaine des as et les populaires
et là sur tf1 en ce moment elle a poussé
un coup de gueule parce qu'elle est
atteinte d'une maladie qui s'appelle la
polyarthrite et son coup de gueule c'est
cette semaine sur les réseaux sociaux et
bien un coup de gueule contre un fan au
début ou parce qu'elle a reçu une lettre
l'accusant de trop se plaindre dans les
médias de sa maladie auquel elle dit
tout simplement si j'ai révélé ma
maladie cette année alors que j'en suis
atteinte depuis des années je ne me
plains pas je n'ai jamais donné
d'interview à propos de mam polyarthrite
mais certains journalistes et c'est
avoue qu'elle s'en prend notamment la
presse people en panne d'inspiration
sans savent s'en servent régulièrement
pour meubler leurs pages vides
voilà donc elle rajoute comme ça on en
aura terminé avec vos myriam écoute là
je suis là si vous lisez des torchons
qui m a titré sur ma maladie pour faire
pleurer dans les chaumières et vendre
leurs magazines
j'en suis désolé salut ne vient pas de
moi je ne résume pas à ça et puis après
elle répond aussi à d'autres fans qui
lui disent tout au moins tu as la chance
de pouvoir se soigner
ça sera un autre débat moi m'agace mais
cette semaine je donnais - mon avis
parce que la semaine dernière on a
entendu que moi donc voilà évidemment je
m'adressais aux personnes de la presse
people notamment peut-être on va
commencer avec l'udc voilà est-ce que
vous comprenez son coup de gueule
alors effectivement faire d une et
raconter n'importe quoi sur des maladies
parce que ça marche et qu'elle est
populaire sur tf1 c'est pas un petit peu
dégueu mais sauf que non mais laurence
boccolini qui en plus est une femme
adorable et sympathique je sais pas ce
qu'il lui a pris aujourd'hui facettes
semaine de dire ça de dire dans la
question c'est pour les gens qui
regardent c est ce que vous comprenez
oui ou non la réaction une robe
boccolini donc non évidemment non mais
quand tu restes à gramat l'a révélé sa
polyarthrite on a fait une brève de
quatre lignes on n'a pas fait de
couverture on n'a rien fait mais bon on
a fait quatre lignes d'un magazine comme
classe quand après trois mois plus tard
elle a redit ag mon ascenseur qui était
en panne et du coup je pouvais monter
les escaliers qu'elle a été à l'hôpital
on a refait quatre lignes magazine rien
sur la couverture mais personne n'a fait
de couverture est d'accord donc elle a
inventé quoi elle a envie de dire alors
je sais pas quel magazine china magazine
ebony du talent le sens qu est ce que
vous vous en foutez ça sera ça ne
s'invente pas mais l'élu du doubs mais
c'est surtout mieux pourquoi elle peut
nous accuser d'un truc qu'on ne fait pas
c'est quand même fou les stars dès
qu'ils savent pas prédire ledesma
l'alcool qui nous fait du mal mais on
sait pas demain la balance beaucoup
on sent qu alors on s'en cogne pas de
laurence boccolini si vous occupez ont
fait au riz puisque vous dites on s'en
cogne tente beaucoup
amélie concours de cris les torchons sur
l on n'a rien fait sur l moche sébastien
non mais franchement elle est en train
de nous attaquer alors que moi j'ai trop
annoncé la presse people
laurence bily dans la rue avec sa fille
avec son mari son amant et où je sors
même temps sur marina maman donc oui
voilà donc non je donne ma les ex
d'accord quelle que soit la situation
dans laquelle je vais croiser laurence
boccolini
je vous promets je chante même pas mon
appareil de mon sac je continue parce
que je sais que ça aucun intérêt
menomena alerté la presse people alors
que la parole ne l'attaquent par non
attendez 7,7 bien mais c'est à dire
d'abord qu'il a écrit mein vous sortez
pas votre appareil photo mais parce que
je sais que je vais pas le vendre c'est
tout contrairement contrairement à ce
qu'elle dit
elle n'est jamais en une de la presse
people ajoute là elle est en train
d'attaquer à la presse people on est
vraiment des produits quoi on est
vendable grande ou mal le prendre
ce qu'il dit c'est à dire que la presse
télé ça cartonne avant la blizzcon y
aller quand elle est une de presque de
la presse télé me laurence boccolini ça
cartonne
les délégués par les matches mais je la
comprends tellement on lui écrit chez l
oncle insultes
y en a marre y en a marre d'après
steeple qui semblait scellé de la
prestine people elle la presse en
général la presse- télé il y en a
laissez les tranquilles elle a dit une
fois et d et e on l'a on l'a on lui dit
tu es grosse t'es moche c'est vachement
bien mais ça leur suffit
un mode daniel et puis après un mode
rachel aussi parce que ça va être
important avec rachel oui si elle l'a
dit c'est sur les conseils d'hélène
ségara qui a fait la même chose parce
que c'est une maladie d'abord so lu ment
souffrir qui déforme les mains elle l'a
dit une fois elle donne peut-être de
temps en temps des nouvelles mais moi je
sais que je ne fais pas forcément la
presse people mais je suis pigiste pour
le magazine ou deux je demande de faire
une interview il ya quelques semaines de
laurence boccolini double page et pages
des photos comme en couverture je
l'appelle elle me dit écoute je t'adore
je le ferai peut-être plus tard je n'ai
pas d'actu et on va encore parler de ma
maladie je n'en peux plus je ne veux pas
ce n'est pas mon actuel il la trouve pas
le voir donc voilà donc c'est pas elle
qui va changer
hélène ségara hélène ségara quand elle
était malade un moment donné elle a
voulu ne pas en parler mais l'été sous
des traits notamment de cortisone elle
avait pris beaucoup de poids et un
moment donné c'était tellement riche sur
les réseaux sociaux avec les gens qui
disaient est boudin et machin c'était
horrible pour elle qu'elle en a parlé
pour s'expliquer faut pas croire de
réseaux sociaux et la presse qu en
bordure bien sûr chicane pardon pardon
pardon pardon pardon un mot à mot de
rachel sur cette maladie parce qu'on me
dit qu'on a droit d'en parler c'est vrai
oui oui non mêlée en fait les gens sont
très méchants et on est tous égaux face
à cette maladie genre ensuite à peu près
témoins parce que mon père à la
polyarthrite
donc il n'ya pas de traitement en fait
pour ça à part des anti inflammatoires
qui te vous avez les jeunes vous aussi
c'est un jeu oui moi je suis supporter
du gène mais je sais pas encore si si la
maladie va se déclencher
après voilà je sais très bien que il
n'ya aucun traitement donc les gens sont
méchants on est tous égaux face à la
maladie dont non mais attendez on se
trouve un peu quand même nous fait que
ça soit faible uc et moi on critique
passe le fait que laurence boccolini à
une maladie évidemment cette super
triste on est un tout compatissant avec
elle ce qu'on critique c'est que c'est
elle qui l'a exposé sur les réseaux
sociaux et qu'elle accuse la presse
people de l'avoir et de l'avoir exposé
non on n'a rien vu à ce qu'on fait on
n'a pas fait pour moi le corps on a
confié hier dernier tu rates and hate
mais comme toute la tas de personnes
donc un moment tu peux pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
c'est horrible horrible théorisé
l'attaqué gratuite alors qu'on n'a rien
fait non mais je suis désormais un mois
pour moi chérie pour moi c'est horrible
ses phrasés même phrase que tu peux
mettre une jolie fille et puis il te et
puis à et pigalle et parce que tu bois
brut ou pas demain au cul et châssis
mines s'est pas saisie voir le bord
l'enjoliveur pasqua a compris coproduite
avec quelqu'un d'intelligent de secondes
c'est pas mentir y aller le point
culture vous enregistrez vous si vous
avez quelque chose chez vous noté prône
un style rigoler non
si vous venez nous rejoindre parce que
voilà elle s'est fait refaire les seins
donc elle a deux double dès qu'ils sont
là elle est comme ça au maquillage
voilà on m'a glissé une paire de seins
et un téléphone voulait vais résumer
elle s'est passé dans l'émission a dû
tourner en a rien à [ __ ]
et là c'est comme ça ta nuque what a mis
un doublé d'une ceni des bus des ptt en
quoi avant pardon un point était en quoi
avant et paris 1 c'était en quoi vente
et herbes et non mais moi j'ai trois
grossesses mais ça on pourra faire ainsi
à chaque fois ces baies celles de
nathalie b un super de la grèce dans les
freins non qu'est sa 80e ces deux
omoplates elle était à chaque fois ces
prêts pour class aura un petit point
club donc tu as fait laisse un tapis les
dents la femip au ac s'est tapé les
lèvres ouais ouais qu'elle soit que ce
bagne à un truc
les femelles les yeux les pommettes et
quoi je me sens bien dans mon corps est
dans mon âme tu adores avec toi je
pensais pas que c'était possible et que
chaque semaine le débat sinon c'est mama
sylla mais qu'on connaît avec de la mort
rôde dans le reste on me dit tu
plaisantes quand tu dis code oui merci
aujourd'hui une mère sujets originaux
mais voilà
là où vous devez pas juste tous les
trois là c'est que vous parlez de votre
presse people la presse magazine sauf
qu'il ya un nouveau phénomène aussi
c'est la presse people que vous avez
vous même mis en place sur le web et qui
mettent des articles beaucoup plus light
est beaucoup plus léger mais qui attaque
vraiment les gens aussi parce que
voici.fr public.fr tous ces sites en
point fr ni balancer zarti toute la
journée beaucoup plus soft que le
magazine mais qui attaquent les gens et
je pense que c'est peut-être aussi de sa
qu'elle voulait pas là ils sont au sol
et il attaque les engelures désolé je
compte bien immo d'animaux à tout lire
et on passe lorsqu'on est dans l'époque
du oui mais c'est oui elle est malade
n'est l'argent oui il a ce truc là mais
ça c'est vrai si l'on rit mais la dame
qui ne l'a écrit c'est vrai mais au
moins tu as de l'argent pendant la nuit
mais c'est une horreur
pourquoi s'en prendre à un autre objet
si elle s'entraîne au genre je l'avais
écrite des lettres
ah bah oui